herzlich willkommen zu zdf heute live
noch zwei tage dann ist silvester dann
geht dieses jahr zu ende
aber in diesem jahr etwas verrückten
corona jahr 2020 gilt eben das prinzip
auch am allerletzten tag des jahres es
ist nicht so wie sonst raketen böller
batterien kaufen um es um mitternacht so
richtig krachen zu lassen wie sonst die
vergangenen jahre fehlanzeige
kein großes feuerwerk am brandenburger
tor an vielen orten striktes
böllerverbot
so sieht das silvester 2020 aus was
dürfen wir was dürfen wir in diesem jahr
nicht darüber wollen wir sprechen unter
anderem mit günter neufeld meinem
kollegen aus der redaktion recht und
justiz schön dass du zeit hast günther
fast viele zettel und informationen
mitgebracht wir haben aber noch jemanden
der uns zugeschaltet ist aus berlin und
der sagt trotz aller einschränkungen
bereiten wir uns in berlin auf einen
ausnahmezustand vor thomas spaniel der
stellvertretende berliner
landesvorsitzender der gewerkschaft der
polizei wurden an das schön dass sie
beide da sind gemeinsam wollen wir viele
fragen beantworten und vor allen dingen
ihre fragen beantworten die sie
hoffentlich rüber feuern zu uns hier in
das studio die wir dann gemeinsam mit
günter neufeld und herrn spanier
besprechen können günter du hast dich
durch viele vorschriften verordnungen
usw durchgearbeitet was ist denn jetzt
in deutschland an silvester in zwei
tagen generell verboten
generell kann man sagen folgende der
verkauf von feuerwerk ganz nicht kaufen
leben dürfen es nicht vertreiben so
kleinkram was das ganze jahr über
verkauft werden darf so kleine
knallerbsen oder also kleine lichter
dieser licht sprühen das schon aber
speziell silvesterfeuerwerk nein so also
kaufen darf man nicht dann darf man es
auch nicht abbrennen oder zünden man
darf nicht müllern eigentlich bundesweit
auf allen besonnen
das belebten straßen und plätzen das ist
auch verboten ansonsten sind die regeln
je nach bundesland nach ordner stadt
nach landkreis unterschiedlich man darf
auch in der öffentlichkeit keinen
alkohol trinken das geht so gut wie
überall das berühmte glas sekt unter
nachbarn auf der straße wird dann leider
ausfallen müssen
und es sind natürlich auch private
silvesterpartys in den wohnungen
verboten
wir gehen gleich noch ins detail wen
dieses verbot trifft was die menschen
auf der straße sagen was politiker und
ärzte vor allen dingen sich aber von der
ganzen sache versprechen ein kleiner
überblick
all die ware darf er nicht mehr
verkaufen für guido wolff rohr
pyrotechniker für großveranstaltungen in
hannover war das ganze jahr schon
schlecht viele veranstaltungen abgesagt
silvester war ein lichtblick war muss
man schauen wie das wie das wirklich ist
wenn es wenn es keine hilfen geben
sollte dann sieht das schon in unserer
branche sehr sehr schlecht aus ein
silvester ohne raketen in diesem jahr
verkaufsverbot liegen corona dadurch das
entscheidungs gefahr sehr groß ist macht
es schon sinn dass man auch keine
silvesterveranstaltung im großen sohn
der stadt verlässt wenn man eine rakete
in den himmel schießt alleine mit zwei
menschen dann sollte da kein verbot
seien aber china böller die auch das
trommelfell platzen muss meiner meinung
nach nicht sein denn an keinem tag im
jahr verletzen sich so viele menschen
wie an silvester krankenhäuser entlasten
auch das steckt hinter dem
verkaufsverbot
es werden weniger mit sicherheit weniger
verletzungen auftauchen und man hat
einfach mehr zeit für andere verletzung
und für andere erkrankungen die genauso
dringlich behandelt werden müssen weil
verstößen gegen die auflagen drohen
bußgelder
die behörden vorbereitet
die polizei wird nicht um den
weihnachtsbaum herumlaufen
wenn jemand aber meint er oder sie
müssen mit großer party über die stränge
geschlagen
dann wären wir eingreifen das ist auch
eindeutig und klar die pyrotechnik
branche jedenfalls trifft diese
silvester hart die ware waschen
versandfertig die prospekte bereits
gedruckt nun bleibt alles lieben allein
hier 140.000 paletten voller bilder also
warum das ganze günther wess von dem
arzt ja schon gehört und der
bundesinnenminister seehofer der das
verbot erlassen hat es eben gesagt das
verkaufsverbot für das
silvesterfeuerwerk schützt unsere
krankenhäuser für überlastung das sagt
der innenminister eben hinsichtlich der
durch die korona pandemie schon stark
beanspruchten kliniken und
notfallambulanzen günther also der
verkauf von feuerwerkskörpern etc
nein aber kann ich denn jetzt überhaupt
noch bologna unter umständen schon das
ist dann von land zu land
unterschiedlich da gibt es länder die
das zum beispiel ganz strikt regeln
bremen malz beispiel da geht gar nichts
nicht öffentlichen plätzen nicht auf im
privaten garten da überhaupt nicht so
dann haben wir das gegenteil mecklenburg
vorpommern
da ist es nur im garten erlaubt ja kann
ich eigentlich schön auch raketen zünden
wenn ich das will ich darf es nur auf
öffentlichen plätzen nicht tun auf den
straßen nicht tun
und dann gibt es so ein bisschen
flickenteppich länder wie
nordrhein-westfalen
da gibt es kein landesweites verbot zum
abbrennen von feuerwerk auf öffentlichen
plätzen und straßen
aber es ist in vielen landkreisen
verboten in kritischen regionen mit
kritischen ins identen verboten
es ist in vielen städten an bestimmten
plätzen und straßen verboten die dann
von der stadt da muss man dann auf der
homepage gucken einzeln benannt werden
und man darf es halt also manchmal ja
und manchmal nein also du sagst es
selber schon teilweise in den ländern
einen flickenteppich wo kreise und
kommunen das dann entscheiden können
also man muss das kleingedruckte nicht
nur für sein land sondern vielleicht
noch für seine kommune nachlesen und
dass das wirklich so ist wie groß die
unterschiede sind sagen wir jetzt auch
ein anwalt
in der grafik dieses jahr mit blitz und
donner in den himmel schicken das wird
vielerorts nicht möglich sein
dadurch sollen die krankenhäuser die
durch corona bereits stark beansprucht
sind von bella unfällen entlastet werden
zwar gilt bundesweit ein verkaufsverbot
von feuerwerk doch beim abbrennen gehen
die bundesländer eigene wege am ende
entscheiden oft landkreise und städte
beispiel bayern hier darf man zwar auf
privatem grund feuerwerk zünden doch es
gelten die ausgangs beschränkungen und
das öffentliche alkoholverbot im garten
oder auf dem balkon mit sekt anstoßen
ist aber erlaubt in münchen hingegen
gilt ein striktes böllerverbot auch auf
privatem grund innerhalb des sogenannten
mittleren rings einer wichtigen
verkehrsader zudem dürfen alle münchner
die wohnung nur aus triftigen gründen
verlassen sekt trinken und raketen
abfeuern gehören nicht dazu schreibt die
stadt auf ihrer website in sachsen rät
die korona schutzverordnung dringend von
böllern ab generell verboten ist es
jedoch nicht auch die seitdem shutter
und geltende ausgangssperre ist zu
silvester aufgehoben ansammlungen sind
aber untersagt komplett verboten hat das
böllern jedoch die stadt dresden und
zwar auf allen öffentlichen und privaten
flächen leipzig hingegen will feuerwerk
nur in drei zonen in der stadt verbieten
die korona üblichen kontakt
beschränkungen gelten weiter berlin
verkehrt in der silvesternacht ähnlich
wie leipzig an bestimmten plätzen ist
das böllern verboten
eine liste des senats zählt 56 orte auf
etwa das brandenburger tor oder auch den
potsdamer platz
dann sprechen wir mit dem der in berlin
ist der spanier
sie befürchten aber das ist trotzdem
nicht unbedingt eine ruhige nacht für
sie von der polizei wird warum berlin
ist schon immer eine metropole gewesen
wurden silvester einsatz sehr viele
polizeikräfte bindet aber auch
rettungskräfte wie die berliner
feuerwehr und aber auch in den
rettungsstellen berlin ist nun mal die
bundeshauptstadt viele hat es in den
vergangenen jahren auch nach berlin
gezogen um am brandenburger zu feiern
was dieses jahr nicht möglich ist und
wie sie gerade auch schon sagt in dem
beitrag 56 burger verbotszonen zu
kontrollieren mit polizei ist unmöglich
und es ist auch so es stellt für die
polizei eine herausragende aufgabe weil
es ist ja es sind ansammlungen zu
verhindern es ist die infektion
schutzverordnung durchzusetzen
das sind zwei maßnahmen aber es kommen
ja noch die anderen polizeilichen
maßnahmen die tagtäglichen kommen hinzu
die funk baden einsätze ruhestörungen
schlägereien und so weiter und das bitte
die polizei und die rettungskräfte
natürlich für große aufgaben
also sie würden sagen klingt ja toll auf
56 plätzen ist es verboten da wo sie
sagen sich naja der berliner findet auch
den 750 oder die andere kreuzung ecke wo
waren das vielleicht dann macht ne
berlin da wo nunmehr fast vier millionen
menschen und es ist nicht alles
kontrollierbar
die personaldecke ist nicht so dick in
berlin gleichwohl wir den letzten jahren
aufgerüstet haben aber es ist einfach
mit diesem personaldecke nicht schaffbar
jetzt haben sie aber auch gesagt
polen ist ja nicht weit weg von berlin
der eine fährt vielleicht mal rüber was
befürchten sie denn da wenn der verkauf
von feuerwerkskörpern günther hat das
gesagt nun bundesweit auch in berlin
verboten ist aber die polnische grenze
ist nicht weit weg aus meiner sicht kann
die böller verbote zu spät man hat er
noch die möglichkeit über den
sogenannten kleinen grenzverkehr nach
polen zu fahren sich illegal nach feuer
werkzeug zu besorgen
man konnte den schwarzmarkt nutzen wie
es gestern in berlin auch passiert ist
hat man gestern ein geschäft aus
ausgehoben wo illegale feuerwerkskörper
verkauft wurden und das bietet natürlich
genügend spielraum noch feuer werkzeug
sich zu besorgen und dann in der
silvesternacht abzubrennen und das ist
ja meist was aus polen kommt jetzt nicht
unbedingt das ganz harmlose feuerwerk
richtig richtig man konnte jetzt die
medien verfolgen dass das feuerwerk aus
polen ja nicht der eu-norm verspricht
und in deutschland geprüft wurde und man
auch noch an den letzten jahren
verfolgen konnte was vor schwerwiegende
verletzungen polnische feuerwerkskörper
erzeugen können ja wir haben genau zu
diesem punkt nämlich hier
eine frage über youtube von zufall y tee
oder youtube ich wollte fragen wie
sinnvoll ist herr spanien
wie sinnvoll sie das böllerverbot
erachten
schließlich wird nun größtenteils mit
illegalem material geböllert so vermutet
eben auch er was beispielsweise aus dem
ausland kommt aber eben dann
möglicherweise noch viel gefährlicher
ist und ähnlich äußert sich gottfried
matthias raths er sagt alle die entweder
nach polen oder tschechien fahren können
also von berlin von brandenburg von
sachsen aus nach tschechien zum beispiel
werden sich eindecken also da ist dann
eben die frage an sie für sinnvoll
halten sie dieses generelle weller
verkaufsverbot
also ich begrüße das generelle
verkaufsverbote in diesem jahr weil es
hat ja auch einen sinn für die
infektionsschutz verordnung mit der
eindämmung die ministerpräsidenten der
länder haben sich dabei was gedacht die
polnischen bonner bürgern wirklich viel
gefahr ich konnte es gestern selber in
einem medialen beitrag verfolgen
es werden sogenannte mutations
handgranaten teilweise verkauft die eine
splitterwirkung von 30 metern haben wenn
man sich das mal vor stellt das bewirkt
schwere verletzungen die dann wieder
unser rettungspersonal auszubaden hat
jetzt haben wir eine frage die bei
youtube jan stellt es macht doch keinen
sinn bürgern zu verbieten es gibt auch
immer wieder schlupflöcher macht es auch
überhaupt sinn frage so ein bisschen nur
an bestimmten straßen als bildern zu
erlauben hintergrund ist ja dass die
krankenhäuser nicht noch zusätzlich
verletzungen durch feuerwerkskörper
haben wollen aber das kann ja überall
und jederzeit passieren die konkrete
frage an sie sagten ja man kann ja gar
nicht alles kontrollieren aber jetzt
nehmen wir mal an sie fahren streife am
potsdamer platz vorbei der potsdamer
platz ist auf der liste der 56 plätze
und orte wo alles verboten ist und sie
sehen da jetzt jemanden der als eine
rakete zündet ja noch vom letzten jahr
hat oder aus holen was machen sie denn
dann also wir werden natürlich
größtmöglich probieren an den hotspots
zu kontrollieren und auch die maßnahmen
zu sanktionieren so wie es uns der in
senator auch vorgegeben hat das heißt
also sie würden wirklich
sagen oder kündigen an dass sie alle 56
plätze tatsächlich sozusagen umkreisen
und kontrollieren
man kann ich alle kontrollieren aber wir
werden das stück stichpunktartig machen
und größtmöglich natürlich die orte
anfahren und auch kontrollieren
jetzt haben wir hier gerade noch eine
frage frisch reingekommen über youtube
von matthias um welche feuerwerks
kategorien geht es überhaupt das ist ja
jetzt eine spezial frage an sie beide
nur kategorie 2 kleinfeuerwerk oder auch
f1 kleinstfeuerwerk wenn sie also
kontrollieren und sagen jemand das auf
dem potsdamer platz das und das darf er
nicht geht es darum dass das kleine
knallerbsen feuerwerk oder reden wir
dann wirklich nur von diesen größeren
raketen oder ganzen batterie also nach
meinem kenntnisstand geht es um das
feuerwerkskörper nummer zwei aber es
wurde auch das tischfeuerwerk verboten
jetzt muss ich günter fragen zunächst
erklärt dass wenn man es steht in den
meisten vorschriften der länder das so
kleines tischfeuerwerk wieso
wunderkerzen ja dass das erlaubt sei es
steht aber nicht drin ob diese erlaubnis
nur für den privaten raum gilt oder auch
für den öffentlich also nehme ich die
wunderkerzen nach draußen oder das ist
ja dann besser lasse im garten
aber günter kommen wir auf silvester
sozusagen zuhause
jetzt haben wir darüber gesprochen über
die raketen draußen das ist also nun
klar dass das eben je nachdem wie die
kommune das regelt nicht erlaubt ist wie
sieht es jetzt mit zu hause aus wen darf
ich denn jetzt überhaupt zum beispiel
einladen kann ich jetzt zehn zwölf
freunde einladen
bleigießen machen harmlos aber kann ich
jetzt mit zehn zwölf frauen zu hause
feiern
nein da gibt es eine relativ klare
bundesweite regelung fünf personen
maximal fünf personen aus maximal zwei
haushalten
das gilt überall außer in sachsen anhalt
da sind es fünf personen aus maximal
fünf haushalten aber nie mehr als 5 und
dann war es glaube ich so kinder unter
14 nicht mit also
kinder bis 14 10 ich mit das ist richtig
so und was darf ich denn jetzt zu hause
machen darf ich denn jetzt schreibt hier
über youtube der legastheniker wie sieht
es denn auf dem eigenen grundstück aus
kann ich jetzt dass kinder feuerwerk
dennoch zu hause zünden auf der terrasse
kann ich die wunderkerzen auf der
terrasse schwenken kann ich vielleicht
eine rakete vom garten aus starten also
wunderkerzen auf der terrasse würde ich
mal glauben ist in eigentlich allen
bundesländern erlaubt selbst die die
sagen strikt kein feuerwerk die zehen
glaube ich so eine kleine wunderkerzen
nicht zum feuerwerk bei rakete sieht das
anders aus es gibt bundesländer wie zum
beispiel eben bremen da darf ich
überhaupt kein richtiges feuerwerk
zünden auch nichts die rakete im
privaten garten und es geht dem andere
da ist es erlaubt es entweder wie in
mecklenburg vorpommern draußen im garten
erlaubt und gibt wieder andere wie eben
sagen wir mal niedersachsen also darf
ich zum beispiel auf einer dorfstraße in
der tiefsten tiefen ostfrieslands wohl
nicht viel los ist am dienstag ein
ausdrückliches verbot gibt von der
kommune oder vom landkreis dann darf ich
auf der straße meine rakete zünden
das ist von land zu land unterschiedlich
also damit auch schon ein bisschen die
frage von ea bvb youtube so kommen noch
fußball in die diskussion mit rein
beantwortet david sylvester vor meiner
haustür feiern mit feuerwerk
fragezeichen also das hängt ganz davon
ab wo man wohnt wo man ist und wie land
oder kommune das ganze geregelt haben
jetzt gibt es ja günther noch eine frage
in baden württemberg zum beispiel auch
strenge ausgangs beschränkungen das ist
ja auch wieder von land zu land
unterschiedlich die sind aber in baden
württemberg so dass man zwischen 20 uhr
und 5 uhr also schon eine lange zeit gar
nicht mehr vor die haustür darf außer
triftiger grund ich muss jetzt zum arzt
und irgendwas in richtung aber im grunde
ist der feierabend freunde also du sagst
dass ein haushalt kann ja kommen
aber dann ist feierabend um mitternacht
er darf ja gar nicht mehr vor die tür
das in baden-württemberg muss man also
nur ein freundespaar einladen und die
müssen dann auch die matratze mitbringen
sowie übernachten also wenn ich dann mit
mehreren
maximal fünf personen aus zwei
haushalten in baden-württemberg feiern
will kann ich tun
ich muss dann aber meinen gästen auch
eine übernachtungs gelegenheit anbieten
oder bis 5 uhr durch feiern dann endet
das ausgehverbot und man darf wieder
unterwegs
es geht aber nicht nur werden wird es
gibt viele ausgehverbote
unterschiedliche art in verschiedenen
ländern auch dann wieder örtliche nehmen
wir mal solche gegenden wie die hessen
da gibt es die nördlich oder einem
bestimmten land kreisen bestimmte
verbote und überall wo solche
ausgehverbote gelten gelten die
uneingeschränkt auch an silvester
gewisse ausnahme die es an weihnachten
gegeben hat gibt es silvester jetzt
nicht mehr
ja und jetzt hinterher in mainz da
trinkt man auch gerne mal ein und stößt
mit dem 6 mit den nachbarn dann aber wie
ist das wenn ich euch sagen wir mal mit
meinem nachbarn draußen auf der straße
noch mal kurz anstoßen über einen
gartenzaun würde gehen aber auf der
straßen ein alkoholverbot kauft euch
goal konsum auf der straße ist
eigentlich überall verboten
jetzt müssen wir einfach herren spanien
mal fragen jetzt haben wir so viele
regeln also wir müssen uns durch lesen
wo was bei uns vor der haustür gilt aber
jetzt die frage an sie an den polizisten
wie will man denn diese ganzen regeln
irgendwie durchsetzen kann man das alles
kontrollieren
das ist nicht alles kontrollieren das
ist nicht machbar weil dieser
personaldecke man muss sich vorstellen
in berlin werden der silvesternacht
ungefähr 2600 polizei waren im einsatz
sein
im letzten jahr hat man für 2 hot spots
also wird zwei bürger verbotszonen
wurden 650 polizeibeamte eingesetzt
wenn man das jetzt auf eine metropole
wie berlin einer fast vier millionen
stadt überträgt es ist nicht machbar
jetzt hat günther jauch gerade uns
erklärt was zu hause alles erlaubt ist
also wie viele leute ich treffen darf
eben auch nur einen anderen haus stand
der maximal fünf personen wie wird denn
sowas überhaupt kontrolliert wenn es
jetzt nicht eine empfehlung ist sondern
wirklich ein ausgesprochenes verbot der
kommune des landes eine absolute regel
klopfen sie als polizist an anderen
sagen entschuldigung pose neues jahr
aber wir wollen mal durchzählen wie viel
sie hier bei der party zu hause an
die möglichkeit besteht wenn ein
konkreter verdacht besteht unseres
gemeldet wird dass mehrere personen in
einer wollen sind dann hat auch die
polizei zugriff zutrittsrecht und kann
es kontrollieren
also das heißt wenn der nachbar jetzt
aber mal sie anruft und sagt ich habe 20
leute da drüben reingehen sehen ich
glaube nicht dass das erstens einmal aus
einem haus stand sind so sind auch mehr
als 5 und ruft sie also jetzt an und
beschwert sich und sagt dass pasta nicht
mit den regeln und sie kommen jetzt
dahin aber zählen sie dann durch sagen
sie jetzt bis nach hause oder was können
sie denn konkret machen wenn jetzt ein
unschuldslamm an der türe sagt ja wir
sind nur drei leute aber sie hören im
hintergrund eine ordentliche party ja
gut wir können uns dann natürlich
durchsuchungsbeschluss besuchen und
können die wohnungen betreten und können
natürlich standen die person die über
die eigentliche anzahl da sind aus der
wohnung verweisen
also sie können richtig die die party
auflösen
ja haben sie das denn schon mal gemacht
ich persönlich nicht aber ich weiß dass
du schon vorgekommen ist
aber was rechnen sie denn aus ihrer
erfahrung sie haben eben auch nicht
erzählt das ist schon schwierig gewesen
sozusagen böllerverbot auf manchen
plätzen durchzusetzen das ist ja nicht
ganz einfach wenn sie in einer großen
stadt wie berlin jetzt auch noch so was
machen müsste man da wird man ja wenn
die zwei polizisten vor der türe stehen
nicht gerade mit offenen armen empfangen
das ist richtig so viele sind ja dann
auch alkoholisiert und der wohnung und
drogenkonsum und und und und die polizei
ist jemand derjenige der dann freundlich
empfangen wird also dann wird natürlich
auch mit gegenwehr zu rechnen sein
und wie sehen denn dann die strafen aus
können sie dann sagen so ich nehme sie
jetzt mit oder sagen sie hier jetzt ist
die sache beendet und auf nach hause
oder gibt es bußgelder wie hoch sind die
wahl zb über youtube sonne auch fragt
wie hoch ist denn die strafe bei nicht
einhaltung der maßnahmen was machen sie
denn dann also soweit ich weiss können
bußgelder bis zu 10.000 euro erlassen
werden wenn man gegen diese so genannten
verordnungen verstößt also insofern
sondern eine klare antwort sich zweimal
überlegen ob man das macht spanien kommt
jetzt grundsätzlich einfach so mal in
die glaskugel so ein bisschen geschaut
in berlin also ich sag mal so aus
italien kenne ich es aus neapel da sagen
die freunde wenn die neapel ein verbot
erlassen ist dann ist es schon gestern
von den napolitan gebrochen worden
wenn ihr diese ganzen regel in berlin
auch gelten und die stadt berlin eben
diese regeln erlassen hat was sagen sie
denn so ein bisschen aus ihrer erfahrung
werden sich viele daran halten oder wird
das jetzt wirklich der harte nacht für
sie also berlin ist ja nun mal wie schon
mehrfach erwähnt habe eine vier fast
vier millionen stadt
es ist ein paar die hotspots berlin
wollen viele feiern
ich glaube auch nicht dass ich einige
davon abbringen lassen gegen dieses
verbot zu fall
sich daran zu halten sondern es werden
werden verstoßen
und es wird auch viele viele illegale
partys geben und man muss sehen wie die
polizei damit zurecht kommt also eine
knifflige sache sozusagen in der praxis
für herrn spanien und seine kollegen
günther jetzt aber nur mal rein
rechtlich nicht das ist ja so ein
bisschen die frage und es verführt
natürlich auch zu sagen ach ja wer will
das denn kontrollieren und da ist jetzt
auf einmal eine party und der nachbar
sieht vom anderen balkon da drüben ist
eine wilde partys wird alkohol getrunken
und die zünden jetzt sogar die ersten
raketen vom balkon
welche möglichkeiten hat denn dann
tatsächlich die polizei also da streiten
sich die experten aber zunächst mal
sagen dass die wohnung natürlich relativ
heilig ist in deutschland wir haben laut
grundgesetz das recht auf
unverletzlichkeit der wohnung darf
normalerweise keiner rein auch keiner
polizei was die kontrollen angeht hat
der spanien eben eine kleine aber
wichtige einschränkung gemacht er nannte
den begriff durchsuchungsbefehl
das ist nämlich so dass ich den erstmal
vom richter bekommen haben muss wenn ich
also da eine party sehe wo ich rein will
müsste ich dann erstmal einen richter
finden den wir einen durchsuchungsbefehl
gibt und dann kann ich mit dem er wieder
zurück und bis dahin ist die party
aufgelöst
ich glaube wer was das spontane und
schnelle eingreifen kontrollieren der
polizei angeht
das kann man gut beschreiben anhand
zweier pole der eine pol ist nehmen wir
den fall eine party mit sechs personen
ein nachbar ruft an bei der polizei sagt
ich glaube das sind sechs leute und
nicht nur 5 da wird die polizei nicht
gleich rein dürfen sie darf natürlich
immer wie jeder andere auch klingeln und
sich den namen aufschreiben und kann
sagen wir haben gehört der seit sechs
dürfte aber nicht aber sie darf nicht
rein
jetzt mal ein anderer extremfall es gibt
ernstzunehmende informationen darüber
dass dort eine party stattfindet mit 20
leuten und da ist ein corona kranker
dabei
dann haben wir eine gegenwärtige akute
gefahr gesundheitsgefahr
und da darf zb die polizei auch ohne
richterliche genehmigung eingreifen weil
sie halt diese akute gefahr dann
bekämpfen muss ich sage mal große party
ein corona krank also jetzt kann man
sich viele fälle zwischendrin vorstellen
und das sind dinge die man im zweifel
vor gericht landen die wir so noch nicht
gehabt haben wo die einen experten so
sagen die anderen anders herr spanier
liegt im hintergrund und das ist dann
wahrscheinlich auch schwierig abzuwägen
für ihre kollegen was man dann genau wie
macht wir haben damit oder du getan hast
damit eine frage schon von jennifer
fortmann die über facebook geschrieben
hat beantwortet wie soll das
zutrittsrecht gerechtfertigt werden ohne
gerichtlichen beschluss oder gefahr im
vollzug das hast du jetzt quasi schon
beantwortet jetzt schreibt aber über
youtube henry 133 was ist mit partys in
studentenwohnheimen wo viele leute zb 14
in einem haushalt zusammenleben darf man
denn da feiern
der haushalt ist das zimmer oder das
appartement henry aufgepasst damit ist
der fall erledigt also nein man darf
nicht also das ganze studentenwohnheim
ist nicht ein haushalt sondern das
studentenzimmer die studentenbude kommen
wir noch mal auf einige punkte auf die
öffentlichkeit das böllern
uns inzwischen einige geschrieben über
facebook charlottenburg warum gibt es
eigentlich kein generelles böllerverbot
quasi von sylt bis berchtesgaden
dann wäre ja eigentlich vieles klar da
müsste ich eigentlich auch sie fragen
erst mal herr spanier
was sagen sie zu dem was wir jetzt hier
schon gehört haben eben diesen ganzen
flickenteppich wäre ihnen das wäre das
der polizei von süd bis berchtesgaden
nicht lieber es ist gäbe klare regeln
die wirklich von der nordsee bis zu den
alpen gelten anstatt eben ein
flickenteppich also das könnte ich nur
begrüßen das ist ein generelles
burka-verbot durch den
bundesinnenminister gegeben hätte und
dann wären klare richtlinien über die
gesamte bundesrepublik gewesen
das wäre sozusagen für ihre kollegen
einfacher die ja zum beispiel könnte hat
das gesagt in nordrhein-westfalen
dastehen und da ist dieses erlaubte als
jenes erlaubt anteil von der kommunalen
grenzen ab polizei ländersache
jedes land hat seine gesetzmäßigkeiten
das ist halt so 16 bundesländer plus
bund sind 17 gesetzmäßigkeiten das
böllerverbot mag man sich wünschen aber
wir müssen wissen die politik darf in
unserem rechtsstaat auch nicht machen
was sie will sie muss ein eingriff in
die freiheitsrechte der bürger jedes mal
begründen und der eingriff muss
gerechtfertigt sein
wir haben den fall in niedersachsen
niedersachsen wollte ein landesweites
böllerverbot machen ist vor gericht
unterlegen weil die richter sagten nein
wenn einer auf einer einsamen dorfstraße
nachts um zwölf da alleine eine rakete
hochjagd oder im kreise seiner familie
dann ist das nichts was irgendwie den
solchen schutz gefährdet was die
pandemie sonderlich verbreitet und da
kann man zum ballern stehen wie man will
aber dieser eingriff in die
freiheitsrechte hat das gericht gesagt
war eben in niedersachsen nicht verboten
jetzt bleiben wir doch mal ganz kurz
beim böllern draußen danach gehen wir
noch mal rein es gibt verschiedene
fragen auch hier bleiben wir mal ganz
kurz draußen darf man denn im garten das
feuerwerk sowie weihnachts schreiben wie
youtube darf man das feuerwerk vom
vorjahr zünden
das kommt aufs bundesland
an alle experten raten ab das sei
irgendwie nicht gut und so weiter und so
fort aber strikte verbote für feuerwerk
draußen im garten gibt es eben nicht
überall gibt es zb quattlender
durchgehen
die gibt es in baden württemberg nicht
da darf man es im garten tun
in bayern eigentlich auch brandenburg
kein allgemeines böllerverbot bremen
striktes böllerverbot überall hamburg
feuerwerk in der ganzen stadt verboten
bedeutet auch im privaten garten hessen
mal so mal so
mecklenburg vorpommern böllerverbot auf
öffentlichen straßen und plätzen aber
nicht auf dem privatgrundstück
niedersachsen auch auf dem
privatgrundstück erlaubt nrw in den
meisten orten überall aber nicht zum
beispiel in düsseldorf in der innenstadt
oder in anderen hotspots und so weiter
und so fort wer sich alle kleinen
bundesländern noch durchgehen man sieht
sehr unterschiedlich ich habe gerade
nachgeguckt und ganz präzise hier das
was du gerade angestimmt da ist auch
noch zu beantworten denn ich wollte
gucken die abkürzung bundesanstalt für
materialforschung sie gibt nämlich eine
klare antwort und sagt sie rät ohnehin
davon ab das feuerwerk die rakete von
letztem jahr zunehmen denn durch
war das jetzt sozusagen die pyrotechnik
die letzten endes feucht geworden ist
der kann man böse überraschungen erleben
dass reagiert langsamer auch übermäßig
trocken aufbewahrt feuerwerk an seine
funktion verändern und schneller oder
langsamer reagieren
und wenn man dann glaubt man zählt bis
30 und die rakete hebt ab kann man sein
böses wunder erleben also insofern man
darf je nachdem wie die regel ist aber
man sollte es vielleicht ganz lassen
weil das allein technisch gesehen gar
nicht so sicher ist jetzt haben wir noch
wald 423 die das haben wir vielleicht so
ein bisschen schon geklärt sie schreibt
ich dachte das böllerverbot gilt nur für
große städte im ländlichen raum gibt es
nur eine empfehlung es nicht zu tun
oder liege ich da falsch günter du hast
schon gesagt das kommt das wunder stand
ist über landeskommando waldfee und wenn
man das erkennen kann könnte es jetzt
sagen aber ich will es nicht nochmal
alle 16 bundesländer durchgehen
also da kann man muss man eben einfach
schauen wo man genau ist allein münchen
sagt eben der mittlere ring innerhalb
ist es verboten außerhalb kann man das
privat vom garten aus machen
also da noch mal ganz ganz ganz genau
nachlesen es spielt zumindest keine
rolle
großstadt ländlicher raum sondern es
spielt erstmal eine rolle ob öffentlich
oder privat also auf der öffentlichen
straße oder wie du schon gesagt hast im
privaten garten und dann hängt es davon
ab wie man die unterscheidung gemacht
hat was das land sagt ob es hingeht und
sagt öffentlicher raum erlaubt privat
entschuldigung öffentlichen raum
verboten privater raum also der private
garten die terrasse
da ist es erlaubt oder manche sagen eben
wie bremen oder andere bundesländer
anderer städte kommunen generell gar
nicht jetzt springen wir nochmal einmal
kurz rein jetzt wird es ganz knifflig
und zwar über youtube schreibt dead snow
ab wann gilt denn jetzt eigentlich der
haushalt du hast es ja schon gesagt also
zwei haushalte können sich treffen jetzt
kommt die knifflige geschichte
ich bin im block down dauerhaft bei
meiner freundinnen das ist nicht
unbedingt eine schlechte sache
jetzt kommt aber das problem von dead
snow ich bin da nicht gemeldet ich mit
zwei personen in einem haushalt bin und
nur einer ist
der andere nicht dann sind das zwei
haushalte ist erlaubt also ich würde
sagen man kann sylvester auch ganz gut
mit der freundin feiern aber ist erlaubt
sind zwei haushaltes für haushalte sind
überall erlaubt weitere gäste wären dann
nicht erlaubt ja ersparen wir noch mal
ganz kurz man liest sehr oft in den
bestimmungen die günther sich
durchgelesen hat ich auch dann heißt es
dann in dem land ich nehme jetzt mal
rheinland pfalz zum beispiel eine
bestimmungen wenn die ganzen regeln
erklärt worden sind die polizei
kontrolliert die einhaltung der korona
regeln im öffentlichen raum dazu ist ein
verstärkter einsatz im gesamten land
geplant jetzt frage ich sie ganz einfach
mal woher haben sie in berlin wo er
haben die kollegen denn in köln
düsseldorf hamburg sonst wo auf einmal
das zusätzliche personal also ich glaube
nicht dass alle zusätzliches personal
haben es gab zwar immer die jahre zuvor
dass berlin mit fremd kräften aus
anderen bundesländern unterstützt würde
bloss wir haben jetzt eine bundesweite
aktion nach der wurde nach der
infektionsschutz verordnung zu
einzuhalten und da ist natürlich schwer
für andere bundesländer noch zusätzliche
polizeikräfte abzustellen
also insofern auch eine gewisse fuchs
man kann ja sagen es wird kontrolliert
aber man bräuchte eigentlich auch die
leute die kollegen der feuerwehr da bin
ich ja ganz überrascht gewesen aber da
sind sie ja sozusagen auch von der gdp
mit der vertreter in berlin
da wir also echte auch geguckt haben
geschrieben insgesamt sollen 800 50
kräfte der berufsfeuerwehr im einsatz
sein also in berlin sowie mehr als 520
ehrenamtliche von den freiwilligen
feuerwehr 120 einsatzkräfte der
bundeswehr und jetzt kommts insgesamt
wird also so wie in den vergangenen
jahren die personalstärke im vergleich
zum regelbetrieb nahezu verdreifacht da
kann man ja nicht sagen
stille silvester in berlin nein kann man
auf keinen fall sagen also wir sind alle
gespannt wie sylvester in berlin abgeben
wird und wir hoffen dass es ruhig bleibt
ich wünsche mir dass meine kollegen der
wirklich einer feuerwehr und der
berliner polizei gesund ins neue jahr
20 kommen ohne große schwerwiegende
verletzung das ist mein ganz ganz großer
wunsch dann ist das ein wunderbares
schlusswort sozusagen aus berlin von
ihnen spaniel vielen vielen dank und wir
drücken einfach auch die daumen dass in
diesem ausnahmejahr rona jahr 2020
vielleicht der ausnahmezustand den sie
erwarten einfach ausnahmsweise mal
ausfällt da drücken ganz fest die daumen
wünschen ihnen alles gute und sagen
vielen vielen dank nach berlin herr
spaniens
das möchte ich ihnen auch und einen
guten rutsch dankeschön ja günther
wir haben noch eine frage bzw
informationen denn viele fragen nach der
silvesterparty am brandenburger tor
das traditionelle feuerwerk am
brandenburger tor wird in diesem jahr
ausfallen das zdf macht seine sendung
vom brandenburger tor die große zdf
silvester show willkommen 2021 die
findet dort statt aber ich habe es
anfang der sendung schon gesagt in
diesem jahr ist alles anders dieses jahr
ausnahmsweise ohne publikum
es wird aber dort von dort live
übertragen
und obwohl es eben eine genehmigung
gegeben hat hat das zdf gesagt wir
verzichten auf ein höhenfeuerwerk die
gründe braucht man jetzt gar nicht
beschreiben
auch braucht man glaube ich günther das
kannst du noch mal erklären aber haben
schon besprochen jasmin kurz schreibt
wie sieht es aus mit selbst gebastelten
böller nach dem was herr daniel erzählt
hat von den erlebnissen die ja jetzt
schon hat mit illegalen böllern sollte
man vielleicht auch die finger im hain
also auf gar keinen fall
es ist ja jenseits aller rechtlichen
regelungen kann man nur dringend abraten
das ist eine extrem gefährliche
geschichte man sollte das bitte nicht
tun
also wenn das bundesamt für
materialprüfung schon davor warnt das
normale legale feuerwerk von letzten
jahr zu verwenden dann doch bitte nicht
das selbstgebastelte ja wir sagen großes
dankeschön günther hast du denn ein
kleines tischfeuerwerk oder machst du
bleigießen in ganz sicherer form zu
hause sind so ein paar kerzen von
weihnachten über die brennen wir ab das
kann man ja auch machen und hast du denn
einmal wasser da nicht ich finde sowieso
eine sache vielleicht noch zum schluss
ich muss sagen die kölner sind wieder
vielleicht ein bisschen einfallsreich da
ist in vielen fädeln also vierteln dass
böller und komplett in der innenstadt
verboten aber die verwaltung hat also
die kölner aufgerufen erfindungsreich zu
sein und sagt mach doch folgendes bunte
folie bunte stoffe egal was ihr habt
farbenfroh an die fenster wenn es dunkel
wird um mitternacht das licht anzünden
lichtschalter und wenn man dann
gleichzeitig in ganz köln um mitternacht
das licht anschaltet dann ist das doch
ein lichter feuerwerk oder ein
wunderbares schauspiel was vielleicht
auch nett ist und vielleicht das ganze
symbolisiert dass man doch mit ein
bisschen farbe und bisschen vorfreude in
das neue jahr kommt günther vielen
vielen dank dass du hier was vielen dank
für die vielen informationen und
antworten vielen dank für ihr interesse
dass sie dabei waren
und wir alle wünschen natürlich einen
guten rutsch kommen sie gut in das neue
jahr 2021 tschüss und auf wiedersehen